[Music]
ever since the quarantine Oh has been
happening that's Spanish for quarantine
if you didn't get it I was thinking of
Quintin quarantine oh but uh you guys
have you guys been cooking more ordering
food more going to fast food
I've been cooking a lot more I actually
started going into my memory bank of
like my childhood and [ __ ] and I trying
to remember the recipes my parents at U
of A spank bank yeah my parents did what
yeah yeah horn yeah they started I
started remaking some of the recipes my
mom would make yeah I want to make more
like the vid amis recipes but I can't
get as easy access to the ingredients
cuz you have to go to like a Vietnamese
market you can't just go to a Chinese
market and get like any you need a
five-spice not five-spice but uh you
call it a little start star anis I want
to make like a soup or something I need
like specific Vietnamese greens that you
can mainly just get like Vietnamese
markets yeah so it's a little bit harder
well I've been craving some hardcore
fast food right I had to get like del
Taco as soon as my two-week warranty was
over I was out I was like give me a
quesadilla gave me [ __ ] that I can't
cook right you can't cook a [ __ ]
quesadilla not the way it's made with
plastic cheese like I need narak
ingredients not fresh [ __ ] I drove an
hour for Cinnabon right well I guess
yeah you're a quesadilla is the easy
[ __ ] but here's the thing right so
fast-food workers at 50 restaurants
across California are gonna go on strike
oh because they just don't want to be
working yeah and they say that they're
not getting enough like protective gear
they're not getting paid enough for like
some people are getting confirmed you
know positive for Kobe and we should be
giving like hazard pay because they want
this right they're gonna demand that
they get masks gloves soaps that's
basic three bucks an hour hasn't paid
enough soap yeah paid sick leave if
you're exposed to the Cova to all on the
job yeah yeah that's all they want
it's [ __ ] basic yeah super like
illegal not to provide those things yeah
but I guess apparently a lot of other
fast food spots are just just right now
like going to bare minimum I'm surprised
they don't even have soap dude more
people now cuz I go to the lines and
it's always packed it is well have you
seen chick-fil-a workers chick-fil-a's
[ __ ] taupe so they have like this I
don't even know where they found this
they have like this whole protective
like like it looks like Breaking Bad no
it's like a like a little shell like
imagine like a attempt for like a little
kid yes it's it goes clear tent that
they have over there my legs are sticky
now you walk around in it yeah yeah the
list of oh man it's gonna hurt your
heart to find out all right we got
McDonald of course Burger King and no
one cares
we got Taco Bell no no carbonyls we got
Pizza Hut subway so we can [ __ ]
that's okay Popeyes oh boy a local my
llama grill it's okay dude creaking they
all they all plan to [ __ ] do a
walkout so I don't know if it's all
locations but I'm just glad Carl's jr.
isn't on here Paul jr. is so good no but
I'm craving it right now I want the
crisps cut fries no del tacos not all
this little it's all good baby that's
good though they show we're in and out
good for you guys how long are they
gonna go without like okay you might not
be able to get fast food from those
spots for like a day or two before these
companies like okay no we got it we
gotta do something because you're some
of the biggest companies in the world -
yeah stupid man that sucks
yeah I'm just shocked that they don't
have soap like that oh yeah are the
companies like at corporate like
struggling that much or something like
haha
have not been that I'm doing that gravy
chance apply soap to our workers that's
gonna be hard as for the people that
won't be able to get those cheap food
though the thing that I need the the
McDonald's and stuff to stay open let's
go ahead now instead that's not
something for burger look compared to
someone that needs like a dollar burger
for McDonald's it's only four they're
only for their cheeseburger like there
anything else like their quarter pounder
cost more than a in-n-out cheeseburger I
picked the quarter pounder over over
what all the time what am i sitting next
to right now from Texas yeah it's all
from California here I picked the
quarter pounder you've been going in and
out a lot I was like well I be I do be
going in and out though because tiffin
Isaac love and out don't eat food you're
not allowed to eat it I don't like it I
refuse to eat right I would say In and
Out Burger McDonald's fries would make
the best restaurant combo well no I like
a fresh feeling of the in-and-out stuff
so everything tastes better you have to
eat it fresh or you get fries well yeah
well it's fresh it feels like there's no
flavor in it to me well it tastes more
like a potato though I don't I want to
eat it the way the chef we type up and
fries everything no but everything about
in and out is that it's the way you
intend it yeah well cuz you can get your
buns extra toasted you can get
everything customized why is bun such a
cute word actually because he will not
go in and out and accept non extra
toasted buns oh so it's all soft and
[ __ ] yeah and it's question onions like
perfectly made exactly you want the
whole grilled chopped up grill how are
you coming back he sees the light you
guys who sees it like we got him I have
a friend that doesn't eat like the
in-n-out burger that's it's prepared
what he does that he takes out the
Thousand Island as in to add like
mustard and ketchup i pickles
nah I do that make you like a regular
yeah that's what I do
so good is because they add the mustard
and then they grill it the toasted
mustard buns you know why it takes so
long to order in and out because you
[ __ ] cute [ __ ] customizing your [ __ ]
orders all the time yeah it does it does
make donald's goes like it's not like
giuliana here Starbucks every morning
here's my order oh you're butchering it
it's an extra hot Grande upside-down
caramel macchiato with soy milk that
sounds like a white girl order so
everybody here order Starbucks in the
morning and most people get a drink and
food and it only takes one line in the
excel sheet her drink without food takes
two lines Wow what if her font size was
different that's not an option
yeah so if you're wondering why these
places can't offer like just regular
like masks and [ __ ] like that in glove
hey I'm wondering that it's the same
issues that the hospitals are dealing
with and I kind of know this too because
of while I was doing the mask fundraiser
the supply chain is flocked in all
directions so McDonald's and all these
guys they have the money but the
supplies are there there's a scarcity
right so what's happening is that the
the franchises that are in states where
by law the workers have to use masks and
all that stuff it's going there first I
don't know what's up with the soap
because I didn't know we had a sort
shortage and soap but what's happening
is when the corporate makes the purchase
and there's only a limited amount of
supplies it goes first to the areas with
high level of confirmed cases of the co
vide and also areas that are you know by
law you have to operate with the masks
and and then so these other communities
you know that are in areas that don't
have those laws they don't get it
because they're not a priority so that's
what this is the corporate side right so
it kind of sucks in both ways well they
should always get hazard pay I think so
it's distracting they're asking for $3
more and I've seen less workers in there
- than before so they're busier there's
less workers sounds okay and I do I
think it's reasonable that if you
contract it sounds okay for them to want
to shake I sounds okay for them - yeah I
want more money okay but also if I I do
agree about the if you get you know the
kovita on the job that they pay you for
two weeks yeah I thought that was legal
that they have to do that because that's
what we have to do we mean uh where
there is a time allotted for sick paid
sick leave but generally not a whole
time that's like you get some PTO like
two days three days and it depends on
how long you've worked for you can earn
one more day so I think also this is now
a disease that's going around that you
can catch because you're working yeah
yeah we get on the job because we're
doing whatever it's not because I we get
it we get it on our own but like I'm
going to work and catching a [ __ ] yeah
but it's also difficult to because I
guess on the business owners perspective
how do you know if you got it on the job
or you were being irresponsible after
work and just [ __ ] around and going
around and being like those Florida kids
that are partying true but then you have
to also be like but the amount of
exposure that they're getting on a daily
serving X amount of customers like the
probability of them catching it ah there
versus at a party for being negligent
for negligent or whatever it was
probably a lot higher yep yeah but at
the end of the day - I do agree that if
they can provide two-week pay for people
who get the co vide on the job or
whatever you're gonna make my stuff take
co feed now [ __ ] Covey's I talked about
Kovac ovd so this has been an ongoing
thing even besides fast food did you
guys know that into the car Whole Foods
General Electric Amazon Barnes & Noble's
warehouse workers have all protested and
walked off the job demanding paid sick
leave and more protection at work
instacart it's [ __ ] up or now like so
like I don't even know bars an oval
still existed
therapy your walk you out of the
bookstore dime like we're about to fail
anyway dude you gotta find some book
series what happened what is the corner
yeah so workers are reporting right now
they're actually getting half the pay
that you did before not only they're not
getting protective gear but normally
before they'd be making like seven eight
bucks in order like automatically
besides tip they were now they're only
getting three dollars in order so
they're paying them less and yes so it's
the cars been in trouble lately
and they just released like a PR
statement going oh yeah now we're gonna
start to provide protective gear blah
blah blah blah but they haven't
mentioned how much they're gonna pay I
don't get it cuz I want to know the real
reasons because like if they just came
out like what McDonald's did here and
then they said guys like we have the
money to buy the supplies we just
there's no supply to buy and it's
limited and that makes me go oh yeah
that makes sense like if you can't find
the soap like you can't provide the soap
it's just difficult it so started to
argue true but I mean like you know
masks masks you can't find it so they
should be able to find a [ __ ] soap
yeah but then yeah like the mask says I
know that firsthand and that's why we're
doing the fundraisers for them but it's
just all [ __ ] up dude I don't know
it's kind of scary to see what's gonna
happen and I just wish and hope that
people as many people can hold their
jobs because it's gonna be crazy and I
want hamburgers every time you go pick
up a hamburger just throw a mask at them
oh [ __ ] that's a good idea trade them
train them some lemons and a mask
[Music]